j'étais même pas cinq minutes c'est
vraiment à la fin que j'ai soulevé mon
haut pour faire une petite vidéo avec
mes potes et tout et puis c'est à ce
moment là que le manifestant ils sont
gilet jaune est venu m'agresser en
tripotent les
[Musique]
22 ans je travaille sur 7 j'ai grandi
dans une petite ville du Jura en
Franche-Comté entre Besançon et Dijon
j'ai eu une enfance et une adolescence
assez mouvementée et rempli de violents
j'ai vécu énormément de violences
familiales de la part de mes parents
mais aussi de la violence extérieure du
harcèlement à l'homophobie puis à la
transphobie que j'ai vécu dans mon
adolescence j'ai vécu des violences
depuis très jeune
j'ai retrouvé des rapports au service
sociaux qui datent de quand j'avais 4
ans où il y avait eu des signalements de
violence dû à des marques sur mon corps
etc j'ai pu ref hospitalisation pour mon
adolescence à cause de la dépression et
voilà et j'ai toujours subi du
harcèlement de la part de de tout le
monde en fait dans ma région d'origine
sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai aussi été
exposé sur les réseaux sociaux assez tôt
ce qui m'a du coupé très rapidement
assez violent cela et au harcèlement en
ligne j'ai fait mon premier coming out à
13 ans c'est un coming out guerre au
début je pensais être tout simplement un
garçon homosexuel
et à partir de là ça a changé énormément
de choses ça m'a libéré je suis devenu
très faible en fait j'étais un petit peu
le cliché de la folle quoi et en fait
j'ai réalisé que ça me suffisait pas et
puis j'avais toujours des
questionnements
identitaires etc à l'époque en plus on
parlait beaucoup moins des personnes
courir on avait beaucoup moins de
représentations et tout bah c'est grâce
aux réseaux sociaux si à l'époque que
j'ai pu avoir un peu des réponses à mes
questionnements sur l'identité de genre
etc
sur les transitions et puis oui ça s'est
fait plus ou moins comme ça sans
forcément qu'il y ait de coming out non
le lycée pas en fait qui j'étais
refusait de d'accepter mon identité en
fait et ça partait loin et c'était
violent et en fait je refusais de me
laisser faire j'étais convoqué tous les
quatre matins chez le TPE ou dans le
bureau de la proviseur parce que mes
tenues vestimentaires leur convenaient
pas et on m'a expliqué au lycée en
garçon de porter des jeans on était
vraiment dans le contrôle de qui j'étais
de ce que je faisais de comment je
m'habillais j'avais pas le droit de
porter des couleurs trop trop visibles
j'avais pas le droit de porter de rouge
à lèvres donc je peux pas sortir de chez
moi en étant tranquille je peux pas je
peux pas juste faire ma vie comme tout
le monde enfin ça c'est le quotidien de
toutes les femmes en fait d'être emmerdé
dans la rue quoi qu'on fasse et peu
importe quand on est habillé pas plus
tard qu'hier j'ai été harcelé et
insulter dans la rue de travelo on m'a
humilié malheureusement et tout ben je
fais escort fin 2021 j'ai réalisé mon
premier film autoproduit et là je
travaille sur le prochain j'ai commencé
à taper occasionnellement et après j'ai
repris à temps plein pour mes 18 ans et
c'est cette année-là aussi je me suis
syndicat au stress le syndicat du
travail et ensuite j'ai commencé
l'année d'après à 19 ans et du coup ma
scolarité
j'étais un métier de la mode et en fait
j'ai arrêté à 16 ans à cause à cause du
harcèlement et de la transphobie et ça
m'a beaucoup peut-être pas sur le moment
mais plus tard ça m'a beaucoup affecté
j'ai un peu regretté d'avoir abandonné
mes études en France on n'aide pas les
personnes trans en fait à accéder aux
études à l'emploi s'épanouir dans leur
vie à cause de toutes ces violences
transphobes tu harcèlement et tout et de
la précarité dans laquelle vivent les
personnes trans c'est aussi pour ça que
beaucoup d'entre nous sont plus sont
plus susceptibles de faire du travail
sex ce qui n'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose mais ouais peut-être que
si les personnes trans en France avaient
plus de chance en fait il y aurait
peut-être moins de personnes qui
exerceraient le travail sexuel je sais
pas quand je me suis mise au travail du
sexe en ligne en fait je crois que j'ai
dû commencer par vendre ta culotte
justement donc j'ai vendu quelques
sous-vêtements sales enfin c'est une
plateforme aussi qui permet de vendre
des vidéos sur ton profil c'est un
client il a une demande particulière
d'un scénario et tout on peut en
discuter et voilà je peux réaliser dans
les limites de ce que moi j'accepte et
tout récemment on m'a demandé un
scénario et tout de vidéo et on m'a
demandé à ce que je utilise un terme
interne réassiste en fait et du coup
j'ai refusé ouais du coup travailler du
sexe
j'ai envie c'est mon travail à temps
plein il y a quelques années
je pouvais pas en vivre et à l'époque je
vivais en squat aussi donc voilà j'étais
assez précaire je suis allé à la
manifestation contre la réforme la
retraite parce que je suis sûr de la
classe populaire enfin et j'ai toujours
été militante j'ai toujours eu cette âme
revendicatrice et mon intention était
aussi de visibiliser les travailleuses
et pour qu'on soit inclus en fait dans
la lutte ouvrière tout au long de la
manifestation les gens étaient hyper
affolés par par ma pancarte d'un côté il
y avait tant lutte et de l'autre la
retraite on la veut même s'il faut sucer
des et en fait pendant toute la
manifestation j'étais même pas cinq
minutes c'est vraiment à la fin que j'ai
soulevé mon haut pour faire une petite
vidéo avec mes potes et tout et puis
c'est à ce moment là que le manifestant
ils sont gilet jaune est venu m'agresser
comme tripotant les
et du coup il s'est permis de venir
tâter pour vérifier lui-même si mes
seins étaient refait ou pas sur le
moment mon réflexe a été juste de
retirer sa main en lui disant que je lui
avais pas permis de me toucher et je lui
ai craché dessus et j'ai repris ma route
en fait il y a un moment où j'ai réagi
un couple un vieux couple d'hétéro qui
avait fait une remarque sur ma pancarte
en disant que c'était râle et pas crête
je sais pas quoi enfin qu'ils étaient en
train de
ronchonner là et du coup je suis allé
les voir en mode bah c'est quoi
l'histoire en fait genre de quoi c'est
râlait pâquerettes c'est toi qui râlait
pas crête tu as un problème avec les
enfin c'est quoi ton problème tu vois
genre moi j'ai ma place ici je suis là
pour pour revendre ce qui mes droits je
lutte pour mes droits en fait j'ai ma
place ici c'est ça dérange bah j'en ai
rien à [__] j'ai reçu quand même
énormément de soutien c'est vrai et
ayant faux et ça fait du bien mais c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on vit du harcèlement
comme ça et que que on est noyé dans
dans toute cette haine c'est assez
difficile de justement faire la part et
garder que le bon le message que
j'aimerais faire passer aux jeunes
personnes trans bah c'est de pas se
laisser faire en fait de lutter pour
pour être respecté de faire respecter
ses droits c'est absolument pas normal
qu'on soit traité comme de la merde
qu'on soit traité comme ça et je leur
conseille de se rapprocher d'association
LGBT d'association trans justement pour
être accompagné dans ces démarches